Jake Sully is a handicapped War veteran
living a monotonous life in the states
his daily routine consists of regretting
his life choices getting into bar fights
and reminiscing his past Glory Days but
little did he know that his life is
about to turn upside down inside out
blue woo Da One Day some officials
approach him and mentioned that his twin
brother Tom has been murdered Jake is
devastated by the news but the officials
want to hire him to complete his
brother's unfinished work turns out that
Tom was planning to investigate a newly
found planet called Pandora that
apparently supports life like Earth Jake
thinks about the proposition for a while
but when the officials mentioned that he
will be paid in millions he agrees right
away following this he is put into six
years of cryo sleep to prepare for the
mission when he awakens he finds himself
with several other passengers on the way
to Pandora Jake was given this special
chance since he and his sibling have a
perfect genetic match in the next scene
Jake and the rest of the crew are
transported to Pandora in a shuttle
everyone is told to wear full face
respirators since the planet's
atmosphere is too toxic for humans to
survive only 20 seconds of exposure will
kill them in four minutes after landing
on the mysterious planet Jake right away
goes to a military briefing where
Colonel Miles quarrich is speaking to
the Gathering soldiers and several
accompanying civilians he informs them
of Pandora's native people the navi and
adds that if they want to survive they
must abide by the laws here later Jake
visits a research facility where he
meets biologist Norm Spellman she gives
him the first glimpse of his own
programmed Avatar it is then explained
that if a human connects to their Avatar
which is a genetically engineered Navi
hybrid they can blend in on the planet
of Pandora and act like the Navies
following this as Jake and Norm walk
into the science department the program
science lead Dr Grace Augustine awakens
in a specially made pod that connects
her to her Avatar Norm tries to
introduce her to Jake but she seems
angry and storms out of the room she's
probably just upset because she has
become the alien grace then confronts
the base commander and a representative
of the resources development
Administration or the RDA Parker
Selfridge RDA is a company that is in
charge of all military and other
employees stationed at the colony she
makes an attempt to convince Parker that
Jake is useless since he lacks working
legs and is not a scientist however Park
responds by saying that Jake is the only
person who has genes like his brother
Tom which is essential in triggering his
Avatar plus he's good looking it's good
for the movie stop asking questions the
next morning Jake and Norm are connected
to their avatars back in the lab soon
after Jake's Avatar awakens in a
separate room surprisingly he can now
move his legs and walk around something
which he hasn't done in years elated he
ignores his Physician's orders and runs
to the recreation area where several
other avatars are participating in
sports and enjoying themselves later
when Jake's Avatar sleeps the link is
broken and he awakens in his human form
next he meets the colonel and Strikes up
a conversation Jake inquires about the
true purpose of their visit to the
planet and the colonel finally lets him
in on the truth apparently Pandora
houses an extremely rare form of rock
known as unobtainium which is worth
billions on Earth the best and the
largest unobtainium rocks are found
inside the community the navi people
reside in but since they will not see
their land being taken over by humans
Jake will have to somehow convince them
to move away the colonel mentions that
Jake has three months to perfectly blend
in with the navi people and persuade
them to find another home if the mission
is successful Jake will be given a new
pair of legs however at the end of three
months if the navi people still refuse
to move a military team will be deployed
which will likely Wipe Out the entire
race the next day Jake connects with his
Avatar and flies over Pandora's surface
alongside Grace norm and some others
soon they landed a place and begin
collecting Flora samples but Jake who is
very new to the unusual surroundings
becomes disoriented and stumbles into a
field of flowers just then a strange
animal a thanator that resembles a
panther comes from behind and chases
Jake isolating him from his companions
luckily he manages to save himself by
diving into a waterfall with the
thanator Roaring over him Jake's crew
looks for him for some time but they
soon leave when it starts getting dark
at night having lost all his weapons
Jake can be seen sharpening a long stick
into a spear meanwhile a female Navi is
observing him from above she prepares to
shoot him with an arrow but stops when a
mysterious glowing entity lands on her
bow at the same time a group of Viper
wolves attack Jake this time it seems as
if he has met his Doom for sure but the
female Navi surprisingly steps forward
to his Aid and chases the Wolves Away
however she is not pleased with Jake and
instructs him to return back to his
rightful place she then prepares to
leave but Jake starts following her he
also requests that she teach him
survival skills at first the navi
refuses to help him but when several of
the mysterious glowing entities from
earlier land on Jake's body she becomes
impressed and takes him to her place
omatikai she also introduces herself as
natiri however when they reach the said
place the navi people immediately become
hostile towards the outsider in
particular natiri's fiancee and the next
in line to the throne tsutei wants the
hybrid human executed immediately
however natiri stops them and brings
Jake to her parents who also happened to
be the tribe's king and queen Jake
explains to them that he is a fighter
and that his goal is to learn about
their culture and tradition when the
queen hears this she Pricks his chest
and licks his blood she then deduces
that he has a pure spirit and asks
natiri to be his teacher and help him I
mean his name is Jake he's clearly from
Canada or some [ __ ] but he seems alright
after a ritual Gathering Jake is brought
to his bed which encircles him like a
cocoon as he falls asleep human Jake is
revived in the chamber in the morning he
shares his unreal experience with all
the scientists including Grace but once
again the colonel reminds him that he
only has three months to complete his
mission the next scene shows human Jake
reporting on his experiences via a video
log that he records after each day's
activities he talks about how his Avatar
is busy training with natiri one day she
asks him to choose a scound a strange
looking animal for his ride initially he
is skeptical about the idea but after a
lot of insisting and because it's free
and mounts usually cost 40 gold he
chooses one and detaches his neural cue
to its antenna he then learns how to
steer the scan and enjoys riding it
later human Jake informs the colonel and
Parker about the enormous home tree the
Navy's residence and a significant
unobtainium deposit beneath it the
colonel sees an opportunity to destroy
the tree but Jake requests he be allowed
to negotiate with the navi and convince
them to leave in the meantime Grace
learns that Jake is being manipulated so
she relocates him to the Hallelujah
mountains a secluded the location of
enormous floating islands that are holy
to the navi it turns out that she is on
Pandora just to research the place and
wants nothing to do with the unobtainium
Rocks one day while Jake and natiri are
flying on their accounts they are
unexpectedly pursued by a torok a
vividly colored flying mountain monster
that hates anything that flies
fortunately they managed to escape to
the home tree and natiri shows Jake the
remains of the former torok she reveals
that the last person to ride atorak was
her great-grandfather who did it to
bring together the five Navi tribes
during a tough period natiri adds that
it has been decades since anyone even
dared to ride a torok with the days
passing by the navi tribe finally starts
accepting Jake as one of their own and
they even hold a ceremony to honor him
after the ceremony natiri takes him to a
place of prayer where they utilize the
nerve endings at the end of their long
hair to establish a connection with a
tree oh mama naterian forms him that he
may now pick a woman as his wife Jake
thinks for a while and reveals that he
wants to marry her nateri is clearly
astounded but she accepts the proposal
and the two kiss after this the new
couple spends their night together under
the tree and Jake gains back
Consciousness in the lab this complex
Kate's things thanks Jake once you go
Blue nothing else feels true in the
morning natiri awakens to Falling trees
and notices a number of bulldozers
around destroying the place she realizes
that they are being attacked and tries
her best to drag Jake to safety
meanwhile at their remote spot Jake is
getting ready to link with his Avatar
and when he finally revives he climbs
onto one of the bulldozers and tries to
stop it when nothing else Works he
smashes its camera system compelling the
soldiers to fire at him fortunately Jake
manages to escape and reach the home
tree back at the base the colonel
watches the surveillance tape and
identifies Jake as the Avatar who
attempted to thwart their mission
enraged he then enters the room and
looks for Jake and Grace while the
bulldozers continue to work and destroy
the omatikaya's sacred Place meanwhile
the Navy's assemble under the home tree
and resolve to battle the Invaders Jake
and Grace protest against it and make an
effort to stop them from doing so
however the warrior sutay tries to kill
Jake after knowing that he and nathiri
are mated for Life despite him being
betrothed to her as the situation heats
up Suddenly both Grace and Jake's
avatars fall unconscious as the links
between them and their human forms are
abruptly broken by the colonel in the
next scene the RDA and Military
commanders are confronted by an angry
Grace who discloses that the navi can
access a network made out of Pandora's
trees that has more neurological
connections than the human brain just
like mushrooms she and Jake then state
that the Navies will never move out of
their place the home tree hearing this
the colonel decides to invade the home
tree and use gas bombs to drive the navi
away alarmed Jake begs the base
commander Parker to allow him to use his
Avatar so that he can convince the
Navies to leave Parker obliges but he
warns that Jake has only one hour to
achieve his objective once he is back
among the navi he informs them that they
are under Invasion from humans and
admits that he is one of them natiri
hearing this pushes Jake for betraying
her trust I thought you were just a real
heavy sleeper she says the other Navi
are equally devastated so they abduct
Jake and gray as hostages after this
they prepare to fight the humans who
have arrived in a large number of flying
ships then the war begins the Navies try
their best but their bows and arrows are
of no match against the human's Heavy
Artillery unfortunately after several
explosions the home tree is eventually
brought down which kills several Navi in
the process during the chaos the queen
unexpectedly returns to the captive
humans and releases them she then begs
them to save their tribe wasting no Time
Jake approaches natiri and tries to
console her but to no avail during the
assault natiri's father is mortally
wounded and as he passes away he demands
that she take his sacred bow and Lead
his people suddenly Jake and Grace
return to their human forms and are
immediately detained for treason Norm is
also apprehended for attempting to stop
troops from shutting down their Avatar
forms meanwhile the remaining Navi
regroup at the Tree of Souls back at the
base Jake and his friends are secretly
released by their team pilot Trudy then
they fly away in her spacecraft and
attempt to reach the navi unfortunately
along the way the evil Colonel notices
them and shoots at the spacecraft Grace
is seriously injured and it appears as
if she is going to bleed out after a
while the group reaches the floating
mountains where Jake jumps inside a pod
and awakens as his Avatar knowing that
the navi will not accept him he then
makes the audacious choice to call upon
his scound and go on a mission to locate
the Turok his strategy is simple but can
easily result in his death Jake then
slowly approaches the dangerous toruk
from above and jumps onto its back
when I saw this in theaters a decade ago
this part made me go whoa then in the
midst of the omadakayan ritual we see
him riding the toruk to the Tree of
Souls this shocks all the navi and they
finally welcome him back with the utmost
respect then Jake asks the warrior
tsutei for assistance in battling the
human Army and the latter complies with
the navi Now by his side Jake attempts
to save his dying friend Grace and even
enlists the Queen's help however all of
their efforts go in vain as Grace
succumbs to her injuries this fuels
Jake's anger and he motivates the navi
to unite and Chase the humans Away by
the end of the day they approach their
rival Clans and gather around 2 000
additional Navi meanwhile the colonel
notices the navi in large numbers and
shifts his attention towards the Tree of
Souls so he orders his men and marches
towards the location but to his surprise
the navi also show up both on land and
in the air Jake is flying on his
legendary toruk while tsutei and the
other Warriors are ready to sacrifice
themselves solves for their land soon a
deadly battle begins and dead bodies
start piling up on both sides but this
time because of the scouts the human
artillery slowly begins faltering in the
midst of all this Jake is pursued and
shot at by the Colonel's dragonfly ship
fortunately Trudy arrives there in the
neck of time and opens fire at the
colonel providing Jake with enough time
to flee on the other hand natiri's
scound is shot down and killed while
tsutei is also killed in the explosion
from the ground natiri observes the
devastation and starts panicking in the
meantime a large bomb ship approaches
the Tree of Souls it seems like the
humans are going to have their way after
all but suddenly through what's left of
the surrounding Forest a battalion of
titanothers Pandora's heavily armored
dinosaur-like animals arrive and start
attacking the soldiers Overjoyed natiri
rejoins the fight with several of
Pandora's species behind her
surprisingly when a thanator appears
nearby it bows to her submissively then
as the military's Ground Forces scatter
in confusion Jake rays historic into the
air to meet the bomb ship he then throws
grenades at the ship forcing it to crash
far from the Tree of Souls Jake also
launches explosives at the colonel
spacecraft but the latter Escapes in an
amp suit before it catches fire and
explodes unfortunately the colonel
discovers himself at Grace's makeshift
Camp he tries to turn off Jake's Avatar
pod but at the same time the thanator
that natiri had linked with attacks him
surprisingly he successfully kills it
with his suit trapping natiri underneath
it but before the colonel gets a chance
to assassinate her Jake arrives at the
scene in his Avatar the two then start
going back and forth but in the end the
colonel gains an upper hand he is about
to finish off Jake but at that very
moment natiri gets up and shoots an
arrow at the kernel impaling him through
the chest without wasting any time she
fires a second Arrow which instantly
kills the colonel however before his
death he has already done enough damage
to Jake's pod because of this human Jake
is awake but having difficulty both
breathing and trying to get a mask on
thankfully natiri shows up and assists
him in getting his mask she then cradles
human Jake and gets a good look at his
real body for the first time oh so cute
in the last scene Jake signs out his
final video log telling us that he has
been chosen to permanently transfer his
Consciousness to his Avatar the film
concludes with a ritual in which Jake
awakens in his Avatar form with natiri
watching over him subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching